新宿から20分くらい
近いね
ありがとう
すごい
これね
えっと
ベーシルとミント
へぇー
これ何?
ルイさん家に食べてたの?
そう食べてた
だからドライヤンしたら
セッキとか
本当に
お花ももらっていいの?
ありがとう
いい香り
ねえ
やすこさん
欲しくない?
少し分けましょうか
私もそのままもないんだ
お客様
今
ミキのせいで今
え?
車が
ミキちゃんのせいで
どうかは分からないけど
でも
正しき選択が
あ~
ちょうどいいじゃないですか
いつ頃フランスにいらっしゃいました?
何年頃?
いぶ前ですよ
25年前?
30年ぐらい
私ももっと思い
私は1905…
なんと…
それこそすごい年代が分かった
1955年からね
61年まで
だからすごくうまいんだよ
本当に
61まで
いや~私まだ生まれてないです
そう?
そうですね
僕生まれたのが61年です
うん?
生まれたのが61年
1955年
それで最初の時にトンコさんにも最初にお会いしたの
あ~そうなん
うん
パリでしたもんね
そうなのよね
うんうん
結婚してましたよね
だから
なんと私も結婚して
それであのミキが生まれたぐらいになった時に
初めてトンコさんになった
あ~大きくなったわねって私はおっしゃったんだよ
ちょっと困ってないですけど
これはパパと
うん
これはいい
これカネです
そう
どうぞ
どうして?
大丈夫よ
ルイスさんここ
さあ一ついったら
もう一ついったら
これやばい
うーん
全部全部
もう一つ
最近カヌレづいてるから
ルイさんよく当てました
あ~これ
おいしい
これ
最近ヒットしてるのよね
これもさ
そう
一緒
一緒一緒一緒
うん
一緒